[Musik]
und in Weißwasser in seinem
Wahlkreisbüro bin ich verbunden zum
Phönix Tagesgespräch mit Tino krupalla
das Bundessprecher der AFD und
Fraktionsvorsitzender seiner Fraktion im
Deutschen Bundestag grüße sie guten
Morgen
guten Morgen
jetzt beginnen wir mal sozusagen bei
diesen Zahlenwerten die wir gerade auch
schon im Film gesehen haben das ist ja
auch schon klassifiziert worden sie sind
klassifiziert worden mit anderen
gemeinsam als schlechte launepartei wie
fühlt man sich als 18 Prozent schlechte
Laune Partei
ja man muss ja einfach die Stimmung im
Land angucken mit den Unternehmern mit
den Bürgern reden dann sieht man wer
schlecht Laune hat und wer die vor allen
Dingen wäre schlecht gelaune verursacht
und das ist die Bundesregierung also von
daher von Herrn Scholz so wirklich
abenteuerlich und auch billig abzulenken
für seine schlechte Arbeit das ist
wirklich schon hanebüchend ja machen
gute Programmarbeit wir haben
Alleinstellungsmerkmale es wurde ja auch
im Einspieler gesagt wir vertreten die
Interessen der Bürger des Mittelstandes
der Wirtschaft und das merken immer mehr
Menschen also das wäre ihre Erklärung
für den Zuspruch den sie gerade bekommen
dass sie sich den Bürger zu wenden
ja wenn die Regierungsarbeit schlecht
ist wenn vor allen Dingen Probleme in
diesem Land und wir reden von wirklich
schwerwiegenden Problem was Migration
angeht was Inflation angeht was
natürlich auch die Energiekosten angeht
alles Dinge die nicht gelöst wurden und
gelöst werden über die Migration reden
wir schon sechs sieben Jahre wir reden
über Fachkräfte die es nicht gibt die
auch nicht kommen also alles Dinge die
der Bürger natürlich endlich gelöst
haben möchte und da haben wir klare
Angebote und auch klare Positionen die
seit Jahren richtig sind und immer mehr
Menschen merken dass wir wandeln uns von
einer Protest zu einer programmpartei
wir haben gute Ansätze immer mehr
Parteien übernehmen das aber sie lösen
es nicht und das wird Aufgabe der AFD in
Zukunft sein wenn wir in
Regierungsverantwortung kommen
wenn sie jetzt gerade noch einmal
formulieren dass sie von der Protest zur
programmpartei sich entwickeln im
Einspieler hatten wir jetzt auch gesehen
dass sie noch mal explizit werden darauf
gelegt haben ich habe das hier noch mal
als wörtliches Zitat dass sie eher eine
Interessen geleitete Partei sind und
keine Werte basierte das heißt wer sie
wählt muss einfach gucken was kommt oder
wie ist das zu verstehen
nein er muss nicht gucken was kommt der
muss sehen dass wir in der innen aber
auch eine Außenpolitik die Interessen
Deutschlands aber auch der Bürger und
des Mittelstandes und der Wirtschaft
vertreten das heißt wir werden alles
dafür daransetzen dass die Energiekosten
wieder sinken dass die Inflation
eingedämmt ist das heißt wir brauchen
einen breiten Energie-Mix mit
Kernenergie aber auch in Zukunft wieder
mit russischen Gas und Öl weil wir
brauchen gerade als Industrienation
vielfältige energieangebote damit die
Kosten sinken ein Ausstieg aus der
Kernenergie und einen vorteiliger
Ausstieg aus der Kohle Energie wird
Deutschland Wirtschaft des Genick
brechen und wir sehen uns ja wir haben
mittlerweile die zweite die Karte der
Rezession eingeläutet immer mehr
Unternehmen wandern ab oder spielen
sogar mit den Gedanken abzuwandern das
kann uns nicht beruhigen denn
Deutschland braucht die wirtschaftliche
Kraft um auch den Sozialstaat zu
finanzieren in Zukunft noch einmal
zurück zur Arbeit der Bundesregierung
Friedrich Merz der CDU
Parteivorsitzender hatte vor ein paar
Wochen mal formuliert die Ampel mache
die Oppositionsarbeit gleich mit die
Frage ist was bleibt dann für die
Opposition noch zu tun wenn diesen
Befund so zu folgen ist dann Tee trinken
oder wie gehen Sie damit um
insgesamt merkt natürlich auch die
Bürger dass selbst die CDU als
Opposition ein Totalausfall ist wir sind
die wirklich einzig wahrnehmbare
Opposition wir legen den Finger in die
Wunde die CDU und vor allen Dingen
Friedrich Merz noch dazu in seiner
unsympathischen Art wir agiert fördert
ja die Grünen greift die Grünen auch in
keinster Weise an diese Ideologie
getriebene Politik der Grünen die in
allen Parteien vorhanden ist und das
soll ja auch in Zukunft der nächste
Koalitionspartner der CDU werden
deswegen schont man sie die führt eben
ins Verderben die Grünen sind die
gefährlichste Partei Deutschlands und
das Erleben immer mehr Menschen aktuell
in dieser Regierungsarbeit aktuell mit
den Grünen diesen allen anderen Parteien
gibt wir sind die einzig wahrnehmbare
Opposition die diese Aufgabe und auch
diesen Namen verdient hat
sie gerade auch angesprochen das ist ja
auch für Sie darum geht künftig auch zu
regieren ich nehme an sie haben zum
Beispiel die Landtagswahlen auch im
nächsten Jahr im Blick haben wir gleich
noch mal ein bisschen auch über die
Zahlen reden aber der von Ihnen jetzt
kritisierte Friedrich Merz hatte ja auch
noch mal ganz klar formuliert als CDU
Parteivorsitzender solange ich CDU
Parteivorsitzender bin jetzt keine
Zusammenarbeit für die AFD diese Tür ist
also zu also wo liegt ihre Macht Option
Friedrich Merz richtig gesagt denn mit
uns wird es unter Friedrich Merz als CDU
Vorsitzenden auch keine Koalition geben
auch diese Zeit ist vergänglich auch
eine Zeit nach Friedrich märz wird es
geben wir werden versuchen natürlich mit
den Landtagswahlen in die nächstes Jahr
in den ostdeutschen Bundesländern
anstehen dort klare Prioritäten zu
setzen unser programmatischen Arbeit
aber wir wollen natürlich diese Wahlen
klar gewinnen wir wollen klarer Sieger
dieser Wahl sein und ohne uns wird es in
Zukunft keine anderen regierungsoption
mehr geben ob Duldung ob Koalition das
steht jetzt erstmal in den Sternen aber
wir werden klar dem Bürger sagen dass es
mit uns auch besser werden kann und
besser werden soll wissen Sie die
anderen Parteien haben noch eigentlich
bloß eine riesige Angst und die Angst
heißt vor der AFD dahin gehen wenn die
AFD sollte irgendwo mal
Regierungsverantwortung tragen das ist
die Menschen den Bürgern der Wirtschaft
besser geht und davor hat man einen
riesige Angst und deshalb bekämpft man
uns
ähm
kommen wir noch mal zu diesem
Landtagswahlen diese ja gerade schon
beschrieben haben also Brandenburg die
aktuellen Umfragewerte sind in der Tat
für Sie vielversprechend aus ihrer
Perspektive 23% in Brandenburg aktuell
Sachsen und Thüringen jeweils 28 % und
damit dort jeweils stärkste Kraft
dennoch die Frage mit wem wollen Sie
dann eine Mehrheit bilden dort
wissen Sie wir wollen und wir sind mit
allen gesprächsbereit die es gut mit
Deutschland meint die ist gut mit
unserer Wirtschaft und unserer
Mittelstand meint und deshalb stellt
sich diese Frage nachdem wir diese
Wahlen gewonnen haben werden und wir
geben uns auch mit diesen Zahlen aktuell
noch nicht zufrieden das will ich auch
gleichwohl sagen also da muss die Latte
auch noch höher gelegt werden wir wollen
deutlich zum Beispiel in Sachsen über
die 30% kommen damit wie gesagt ohne uns
keine andere Regierung möglich ist und
das ist ein klarer Bürger Wille und ein
Bürgervotum und da können sich die
anderen Parteien nicht ewig verschließen
Sie wissen alles was sie außerhalb der
AFD werden ist grüne Ideologie
verhindert Wohlstand führt weiter zu
Sanktionen die vor allem die deutschen
bezahlen müssen und das wollen wir
verhindern und da haben wir in ganz
klares gegen Konzept auf die Beine
gestellt Herr und wenn wir noch quasi
zum Ende uns noch Zeit für zwei
Sachfragen können dann komme ich jetzt
noch mal darauf zurück was sie gerade
formuliert haben
gegen grüne Ideologie eine andere Arbeit
machen wir haben gerade das GEG also das
Gebäude Energiegesetz was möglicherweise
nächste Woche den Bundestag erreicht wie
sehr denn die Lösung der AFD aus für
diesen heizungsumbau
wissen Sie wir reden hier über ein
heizungsumbau und die niemand will und
den vor allen Dingen niemand finanzieren
kann von daher wozu braucht es diesen
Heizungsanlage wir haben immer unsere
klare positioniert
ja die wenn Sie glauben dass man damit
Klimaziele in welcher Form auch immer
erreicht dann ist das wirklich ein Stück
weit im Märchengeschichten die man uns
hier erzählt noch mal wir haben als
Übergangstechnologie Gas und das
brauchen wir auch wir brauchen ihn
Wiedereinstieg um diese wenn man diese
Klimaziele erreichen möchte wenn man
davon überhaupt spricht dann bräuchten
wir die einen den Einstieg wieder in die
Kernkraft und das hat man alles
verhindert das hat man weggeschoben wir
kaufen in Zukunft also Strom im Ausland
ein mit dieser sogenannten wärmewende
auch mit Photovoltaik und Windkraft noch
dazu die nicht speicherferien in
Deutschland ist kann man ein Industrie
Land wie Deutschland nicht
zukunftssicher und günstig mit Strom
versorgen wir sehen uns aktuell deshalb
noch mal Energie Mix auch in Zukunft
wieder mit russischen Gas und russischen
Öl vielleicht ein zweiter Punkt noch in
der Tat das ist ein Thema gewesen mit
dem sie bisher immer gepunktet haben EU
Asylpolitik da gibt es jetzt Bewegung es
gibt ein verschärftes Konzept durch die
EU-Kommission und viel Sympathie dafür
in Deutschland bereits ein Außengrenzen
das jetzt auszutesten und sozusagen
erste Verfahren dort abzuhalten
gleichzeitig gibt es direkt aus Sachsen
also aus ihrem Bundesland dann einen
Vorschlag des Ministerpräsidenten die
Zahl der Asylanträge in Deutschland auf
200.000 zu begrenzen pro Jahr das geht
doch in ihre Richtung hat oder
ja das sind alles
wohlweisliche Dinge die man natürlich
hier auch auswahlkampfzwecken wie es
Herr Kretschmer in Sachsen macht
natürlich jetzt fordert er regiert in
Sachsen im übrigen auch mit einer grünen
Partei also dann soll er seinen
Koalitionsvertrag aufkündigen denn die
Grünen wollen genau das Gegenteil noch
mal das geht sicherlich in die richtige
Richtung wenn man solche Maßnahmen
fordert aber wir reden seit sieben acht
Jahren davon also wo bleiben denn die
Umsetzungen wir fordern endlich dass es
auch zu Kontrollen und ich sehe es hier
bei uns in unseren in meinem Wahlkreis
an der polnischen Grenze ist auch hier
Kontrollen an der polnischen Grenze gibt
das lehnt Frau Feser die Innenministerin
ab sie sagte sei nicht schlimm genug
also wie schlimm muss es denn werden und
diese Dinge sind eben nicht gelöst und
das sehen die Bürger wir fordern ganz
klar Sicherung der deutschen
Außengrenzen aber auch der europäischen
frontext muss endlich so ausgestattet
werden dass man hier klar auch die
Rückführung vor allen Dingen der nicht
berechtigten also die Bewerber
durchzieht und du Unfall führt das
gehört dazu und das sind alles Dinge und
Maßnahmen die wir seit Jahren fordern
und immer mehr Menschen sehen dass diese
Forderung richtig sind aber man muss es
endlich
anpacken die Bürger wollen und das will
ich vielleicht abschließend sagen egal
von welcher Partei Probleme gelöst sehen
und sie sehen aktuell von dieser
Bundesregierung keine Probleme gelöst
sondern immer neue geschaffen das war
völlig Tagesgespräch Tino krupala der
AFD Bundessprecher und
Fraktionsvorsitzender seiner Partei im
Deutschen Bundestag danke für Ihre Zeit
Grüße
vielen Dank